[Música]
les traigo un acertijo que nadie lo ha
podido responder bien hasta el día de
hoy un padre estaba acompañando a su
hijo para una entrevista de trabajo muy
importante los dos estaban juntos cuando
el joven recibió una llamada la persona
que le llamo le dijo hijo todo saldrá
bien porque soy gerente general de esa
empresa y yo sé que tú tienes el perfil
que estamos buscando la pregunta para
ese archivo es cuál relación tenía la
persona que llamó con ese joven pues
sabemos que la persona que llamó no pudo
haber sido su padre su padre estaba con
él en ese momento les doy cinco segundos
para pensarlo y después les les voy a
dar mi respuesta
la persona que llamó era la madre del
joven cada vez que hago esta ser chico y
yo escucho respuestas como el joven
tenía padres y por eso un padre le
estaba acompañando y otro padre le llamó
hoy escucho de respuestas como era una
voz divina del cielo pero muy pocas
personas logran decirme que era una
mujer que llamó es nos demuestra que
cada vez que hablamos de liderazgo
muchas veces muchas veces pensamos en la
figura masculina y no cualquier hombre
sino un hombre grande con un bus
imponente y con los recursos económicos
altos pero no se tiene que ver así
porque el liderazgo no es una calidad
influenciado por el sexo de la persona
una mujer puede ser un buen líder un
hombre y también
a través de los años se ha desvalorizado
el liderazgo impartido por las mujeres
en mi continente áfrica con 55 países
solo un país en la cual se encuentra una
presidenta y ese país es etiopía hoy en
día en latinoamérica no hay ningún país
en la cual hay una presidenta peor en
los combates indígenas condados rurales
en la cual las mujeres no pueden liderar
y yo me quedo pensando pero que está
pasando porque hay tan pocas mujeres en
el liderazgo será que las mujeres no
pueden ser líderes
bueno hoy vengo a contarles mi historia
y los retos que tenía que enfrentar como
mujer para ser la líder que yo soy hoy
usando un país llamado camerún está
ubicado en el centro de áfrica
yo nací y crecí y aún de una ciudad
hermosa en la cual hay edificios altos
una calle de calles grandes y también
muchos árboles tildó en color verde y
muy lindo
desde que nací yo siempre supe que mi
vocación es del servicio a mí me encanta
me encanta ayudar a las personas me
encantan los trabajos voluntariados sin
embargo yo pensaba que nunca voy a tirar
un impacto tan grande que hubiera tenido
si hubiera nacido hombre
aunque yo era tan buena afuera adentro
era muy rebelde mi familia que tengo en
hermana una hermana mayor y me gustaba
pelear con ella ella es mi hermana karen
que nos quienes nos están acompañando
hoy y a quien yo mando un fuerte abrazo
cuando cumplí 12 años todavía era muy
ignorante sobre lo que esta sexualidad
me daba mucha vergüenza conocer ciertas
partes de mi cuerpo y yo no sabía lo que
es una relación encima de hecho pensaba
que los niños caen del cielo puede
pueden imaginar esto
les comento que a esta edad siendo tan
ignorante yo fui acusada por un familiar
y él se me dijo con imágenes muy fuertes
que me costaron quitármela de la cabeza
le quería contar estas a mis padres pero
tenía mucho miedo entonces pedía ayuda a
una amiga y ella me aconsejó que no
contarlo a nadie porque iba a ser una
gran vergüenza para la familia yo me
sentí muy descuidada me sentí inferior e
incluso llegué a decirme que éste podía
pasar otra vez y tendrá que aguantarlo
por ser mujer
pasó el tiempo y llegó el momento de ir
al colegio yo fui a un colegio que no
tenía un tanque para almacenar agua
durante la larga estación de sequía
entonces nos tocaba caminar kilómetros
para encontrar agua potable y muchas
veces el agua que encontrábamos no era
apta para el uso humano pero nos tocó
tomar está agua y también bañarnos con
esta agua vivir mi menstruación en estas
condiciones fue algo muy fuerte porque
uno como mujer necesita más agua de lo
normal para bañarse y para lavar su ropa
interior durante la menstruación
entonces yo salí del colegio con muchas
infecciones vaginales
yo tenía síntomas como son picazón es a
nivel de la vulva tenía
flujos muy altos que manchaba mi
uniforme y también tenía un olor fuerte
y me me hacen sentirme incómoda en
frente de las personas especialmente en
frente de los chicos a mí me gusta
bailar pero en este momento tenía una
autoestima muy bajo no podría estar en
público y decirme que nunca voy a hacer
la líder que siempre quise ser
bueno después del colegio gracias a dios
mi madre pudo pagar por mis gastos
médicos pero eso nunca quitó la
sensación que tenían y yo aplique por
varias universidades universidades en
camerún y todas me rechazaron me quedé
en casa ha ayudado mi madre porque ella
es cuestión era la ayudaba en la cocina
un día llega mi hermano y le encanta la
economía y él quería ser estudiar en la
universidad aquí en costa rica y él me
dijo brenda vamos a aplicar para la
universidad y yo no quería aplicar
porque usualmente elijan a una o dos
personas en todo el país y mi país en
ese momento tenía una población de 21
millones de personas entonces yo me dice
que nunca voy a hacer la persona
dirigida
el logro el logro calentarme para para
que aplicamos juntos los dos aplicamos y
yo fui elegida y él no quiero agradecer
a este hermano mío porque sin él no
hubiera estado aquí
desde el ya que llegó a la universidad
cambió mi vida
completamente los primeros meses aquí en
costa rica no eran tan fáciles por el
idioma el gallo pinto todas las mañanas
el choque cultural sin embargo éste me
ayudó mucho a fortalecer mi relación con
dios yo empecé a orar más empecé a
reflexionar más sobre mi vida y me ayuda
a ser una mejor su hermana
con el tiempo yo hice amistades muy
lindas en la universidad en la
universidad que me apoyaron ya no me
dieron solo como mujer me vieron como
una líder empecé a hablar con chicas de
diferentes culturas y ellas me contaron
sus historias y yo les contaba la mía y
así nos apoyamos entre mujeres
y yo decidí bailar por primera vez en
público y todo salió muy bien a la gente
le encantó y desde allí me convertí en
la instructora de zumba en la
universidad a través de mi baile yo he
ido a combates rurales a cóndores
indígenas para dar clases de zumba como
lo pueden ver tal vez yo no tengo los
recursos económicos suficientes para
alimentar a una comunidad entera pero a
través de mi clase yo puedo ayudar a la
gente a su salud emocional y también esa
es mi manera de compartir la alegría
después de dos años de haber estudiado
aquí yo regresé a mi país y gracias a
una fundación costarricense pudimos
implementar un proyecto en la cual
educamos a alrededor de doscientas niñas
y mujeres sobre la higiene menstrual y
también y también tocamos el tema de la
educación sexual y ese es manera de
combatir
la discriminación de género y la
violencia de género también
yo no quería que me impactó su resistida
dentro del país quería llegar a más
países fuera
de camerún y también adentro de mi
continente entonces yo empecé un
proyecto llamado my africano man utd en
la cual es una plataforma en la cual no
sólo hablamos de educación sexual sino
también yo invito a mujeres exitosas
para que ellas pueden contar sus
historias los retos que tenían que
enfrentar así ayudando a más mujeres y
hoy me considero el líder porque
lo que hacen los líderes es identificar
un problema en su comunidad y resolverlo
y es lo que estoy luchando para hacer
en fin la niña chiquitita que pensaba
que ser mujer significa ser débil se
convirtió a una mujer a una gran mujer
que piensa que ser mujer significa ser
valiente entonces hoy me gustaría
compartir con usted tres aprendizajes
que yo entiendo de mi historia el
primero aprendizaje es la importancia de
ser espiritual llámele dios llame de la
naturaleza ya mira el universo pero es
siempre es importante poder conectar con
algo espiritual porque a veces en la
vida hay momentos de mucha incertidumbre
mucha tristeza y la familia ni los
amigos no nos pueden ayudar pero ahí a
través de la oración la meditación uno
puede salir adelante
el segundo aprendizaje es el apoyo que
tenemos que darnos entre mujeres cuando
nos juntamos entre mujeres tenemos que
hablar más allá del cuchilla no hablemos
de ideas de metas de proyecto porque así
podemos salir con proyectos grandes con
la cual podemos
desarrollar nuestras comunidades y
también empoderar a más mujeres
el tercer aprendizaje que tengo esto
tenemos que tener miedo a experimentar
nuevas cosas que nos guste y que son
buenas cosas yo pienso que la vida es
como una investigación científica en la
cual no hay fallas sólo existe el éxito
y el aprendizaje significa que cada vez
que pensamos que estamos fallando
estamos aprendiendo
con esto me gustaría estirar esta charla
diciendo que no podemos seguir esperando
para hacer llamadas a la mesa del
liderazgo tenemos que traer nuestras
sillas sin ser evitadas muchas gracias
y si vas
[Música]
y media
sí
[Música]
si deseamos
en este punto se ocupa de que le
confirme o tiene para más fotos el
sistema de una
vacuna eficaz cuando hacemos su pedaleo
mejor
se hace
la mujer
[Música]
sí
no
[Música]
por eso
estamos
sí
d
[Música]
cuál es
quiero darle más aire a la misma
no lo sé
[Música]
avn a
su mami
[Música]